ce qu'elles vont vraiment faire ça oui
et elle va le lancer à Michel Michel va
attraper le bouquet de fleurs et vous
allez vous marier ta vie serait toute
insulte j'ai grandi en me demandant si
je serai capable de me tenir devant
quelqu'un de lui promettre le reste de
ma vie et nous y voilà
je suis désolé c'était un réflexe
c'était le pire moment de toute
l'histoire des femmes coincées avec des
idiots dans ton genre
tu as 24 heures pour me dire qu'on va
quelque part
je suis toute nue en dessous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ici regarde maintenant tu
comprendras
avec ma femme si tu franchis cette porte
je trouverai une façon de te tuer et
m'en tirer sans problème je n'y
arriverai jamais avec cette bague à mon
tour
c'est comme ça qu'on fait ce sont des
professionnels
le symbole de notre amour cet alliance
est synonyme d'engagement elle est où
ton alliance
maman Michel veut qu'on se marie elle
veut qu'on soit heureux dans le futur
moi je trouve ça plutôt romantique
pourquoi on a encore jamais rencontré
ses parents nos enfants couchent
ensemble ça nous donne même pas droit un
petit souper mes parents souhaitent vous
inviter à souper non hors de question
pourquoi tu ne veux pas rencontrer ces
gens qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait bien avoir
en commun avec eux
[Musique]
sans plaisir de pouvoir faire enfin
votre connaissance merci beaucoup
il est pardon pour le retard
c'est moi l'éviter c'est mon fils Alain
à côté de votre femme au bras de votre
fille
est-ce que quelqu'un a envie d'un verre
les plus beaux moments de nos vies c'est
à cause de toi à cause de toi
[Musique]
vous êtes amoureux de ma femme non merde
mais comment je peux savoir si je l'aime
devrait être posé la seule unique
question qu'il y a à se poser est-ce que
cette fille en elle suffisamment de
potentiel pour aspirer ton âme
telenosphère as-tu non alors fonce mon
fils
[Musique]